What questions you want to ask
me about Anthony? Bordain well,
I wanted to talk to you about suicidal
thoughts because you are out of the
people that didn't kill themselves
with you are a lot, huh?
The one who knows the most about it
and you've experienced depression,
you know, and when I wasn't
close with Anthony Bourdain,
but I really liked him a lot
when I'm with you once. Yeah.
And when I hung out with him, I
really enjoyed it. I did a show,
we did an episode of his show in Montana
and we went camping together and got
fucked up by a campfire. Yeah, it was
great. We had a great, great old time.
It was really fun.
But I was stunned when that happened.
And uh,
I mean I don't,
I just wanted to know like
when you were at your worst,
when you were having like
really shitty feelings,
like what could have been anything that
someone could have done that could've
helped you? Oh yeah. I
think about this too.
I lost a friend to suicide
and it was like, yeah,
you want to stop because like what,
what, what could give done, right. Yeah.
I mean sometimes just all follow
me into a therapist that fuck,
I couldn't afford. I mean I've told
you this before, I probably on here.
That was like a physical thing to do,
but just getting me to go to accept
like that maybe it'll work well, I,
I knew when I was talking to you, that
is a hard thing for you to talk about.
So if you're bringing it up,
it's a real, real issue. Yeah.
Yeah. It's, you're stoic.
Yeah. You're, you're not,
you don't complain about
that with my negative stuff,
he's done. So I remember we were playing
pool and I was like, what's matter?
Like there's something going on,
like you just seem like just unhappy or,
and so once we got you into
that psychiatrist and then dude,
you popped out of that thing, like a
fucking spraying pills. Yeah. Neat.
You went running. Like anybody
who thinks that pills are all bad,
I don't think anything's all anything.
Yeah.
I think I know the black and white
problem where there are people,
like I talked to Ben, she won, it seems
like there are over prescribing pills.
I'm like, they worked for me
and he's like, well, I probably
didn't. I'm like, no, no,
no. Just because you think
they're over prescribing,
it doesn't mean they should never
prescribed they're stuffed. It works.
And sometimes it works enough for you to
just change your way of looking at the
world and change a reality and then you
eventually weaned yourself off of them,
which is really interesting.
Well,
it's a sprain of the brain
muscle is what's happened. Um,
I don't, it's not like a
physical like pull like that. Um,
but that's really what it is.
Just a sprain. And so like
until you get off it, uh,
to get on a cast, if some way it's
going to be real hard for it to heal.
[inaudible] you know,
this is like so far this metaphor works.
No, that does help. I stop.
But I think it works in the most
effective cases like yours of medication.
So these pills act as a cast.
And then at some point you're healed
and you don't need them anymore.
But the problem is,
the only way to really know is if you
just get off it and run on it and then
you're like, oh fuck, I'm still hurt.
And during that get off and run
on a time is when you're suicidal.
Thoughts shoot up if they were going to.
So when they do wean you off,
they're like, you need to keep up
with me. Like any salt you get,
you need to call me immediately.
You can do right back on.
Like what was interesting with you is
you are weaning off coincided with huge
success in your career. Yeah, I got
off him. I know where I got off on,
it was my second apartment in New York,
so this was three and a half years ago,
four years ago maybe around there.
This is not happening is already on
comedy central. It's things are going,
things are going good. Your tours,
kicking ass, everything's great.
And then you released my first
hour and then my second hour. Yeah.
And you were a legit success.
He'll blow up. Was getting,
you were on billboards.
So beyond that I was,
I mean more importantly was I was
a working comic. I was like, oh,
I can make a real living at
this now for the first time.
So that was like the best part. Yeah.
And that hadn't been going on very long.
Right? Well, it was a hot, it's a fucking,
people don't know. People don't know.
It's a fucking crazy struggle.
The struggle from open mic
or too successful working
comedian and everybody's
different, everybody's got their own
weirdness that they have to overcome,
but it's a long ass bloody
struggle by the way.
That's why I hate this infighting
and comedy. It's terrible.
And it's like you're doing this
wrong. You're Dong of just said, guys,
we're all up against the
most monumental odds.
So you write safety safe show jokes
and this guy writes Dick Jokes.
It's like whatever. That's just like
predispositions, but like it's hard.
We're all in the same boat.
Yeah. Anyway. Yeah, I agree man.
And that dot.
It didn't,
it's very rarely been the case in the
history of comedy that everybody kind of
got along and just accepted the fact that
everybody does things differently and
not make, not, don't make
a big deal out of it. Yeah.
We'd have to have factions inside of r
one. You want to have a safe space show?
I get it. Yeah. People don't want
to hear shit like that. It's okay.
Have you ever been a show Black Knight?
And that's fine to have everything.
Everyone's defensive.
Oh my.
Everyone wants to hold their ground and
stand up for their position on things.
It's like, okay, you're going to be fine.
Everyone's going to, because we've just,
it's the best time to be time every
just kick ass. Just keep writing.
Just go out there and do it. Um,
yeah. And then it got better.
But a lot of that was it the focus
I was able to get because of these,
it was rent. Uh, no, nope, not Wellbutrin.
I try Wellbutrin.
The problem is some of these pills,
like the side effects are not worth it.
So what I tell people,
like someone had a problem
once, a fucking anxiety, um,
use of, I don't care about this
shit Nikki stuff and um, and uh,
he's right now planning
on bombing embassy. Um,
and it was like he didn't want to go on
it cause he was afraid it would make him
like a Zombie and I'm like okay,
if it does just go back off it,
you don't have to commit forever.
Right. You know what I mean?
Just see what the effects are. So on I
think Wellbutrin, uh, I couldn't come.
Oh it was fresh.
I,
I wouldn't even say it was any sort of
psychopath or anything cause I didn't
know about that as a side effect until
that was happening with my girlfriend at
the time. And I was like, what the
fuck? It was like three times in a row.
I was like, I just couldn't come. And then
she was like, oh maybe it's those pills.
I'm like, why? Really? And then I looked,
I was like, oh yeah, fucking annoying.
It's an annoying thing.
That's super annoying.
There was this one called rem or Ron,
think about like how many circuits there
are so much in there and they'll think
it's something that gets in there
and fixes this because I can't,
I'm gonna take that away. You
edit your own computer. My God,
I'm like taking those.
It's almost like you edit your own op.
Remember we went to u have a, a PC. You
can get into dos fragment do shit. Yeah.
That's almost like what you're doing.
So the side effect on run run,
these side effects don't
hit everybody the same.
And what's you're looking to fill in?
Isn't it all the same?
So don't just get with somebody else
gets you got to talk to a therapist.
But like Rem Ron gave me hyper Phasia oh.
Which is the inability to be feel full.
So they said expect to gain
15% of your body weight. Uh,
and I could eat dude,
if I got high,
I could eat like eight
plates of Spaghetti. I mean,
I would eat out my whole
apartment. Holy Shit. Everything.
It got to the point where I was like,
well,
I got one big left and peanut butter
and some a little bit of Cheerio's and
fucking let's do this. Hey was, it was
glorious, but that it wasn't helping me.
That was a problem.
That was a side effect because I
was thin then I could've dealt with,
I can be 15 pounds overweight
instead of 10 pounds underweight,
but like it didn't help
me mentally. Mm. Fuck.
Um, and then I finally got on one to
sit for me. That was like, it worked.
I was like, boom, I'm out. I get
it. I'm free now a little bit. Um,
but low blood pressure.
So sometimes I stayed up,
I got to hold onto something and like,
it's not fucking faint,
but barely ever happens.
Totally worth it.
And that still happens now when I get
high. But like do you get like dizzy,
lightheaded? Yeah. I stand up. I'm
like, hold on, you got to get real high.
Went for that to happen
or early or something like
that. Or if I'm getting sick,
that'll happen.
But I used to get that in high school too.
I think I'm already predisposed to it,
but they made it a little worse. Not,
not a big deal though. So I finally
found the one that worked for me,
but it's hard and if you're not having it,
your brain is lying to you or it's giving
you a version of reality that's like,
I mean,
I saw this last night coming home from
the airport from Burbank airport and some
lady picks up an Uber,
picked up a guy on the wrong side
of the fence and she was, sorry,
it's my first time here.
But like,
it's one of those little fences you
can just step over almost, you know?
And he's like, well, everyone else is
going on here. Which is like, yeah, sorry.
It's my first time at the Burbank airport.
I can,
and you can't get a walk 10 seconds to
where it's an opening and he's lying.
He's like, pop the trunk, pop the
trunk place. And I'm like, Oh,
you're cranky from flying.
I know what that is.
And so your version of this reality is,
this is a way worse thing than it really
is. Steve Simone who never gets upset,
which was like, I no big deal. I'll just
come around and then it's over. Yeah.
It's the same thing we've talked to
Fitzsimmons like you can just not punch
somebody and then forget about
it, but you know, if you're,
if you're thinking that
angrily all the time,
it's really affects you and this shit
makes you think the worst of everything.
Wow. It's like, yeah,
no matter what it is a little worse
than it should be an interesting way of
looking at it.
Yeah.
And it just gets tiring after awhile and
the suicidal thoughts start happening
when you're like,
I can't do this anymore.
You know, it's effort. It's mental
effort to just like, oh, it just keeps,
it's like you've got to rock
on you that you're pulling up,
pushing off you at all times and
you just need the game to be over.
You just need a sleep.
The Yvonne used to have a bit about,
I think he probably didn't have
special or something by now,
but it was like if you want that
deep sleep, that deep sleep,
like that's what it is,
where you just want to sleep forever.
You just weighed down by it
all the time. Yeah. It's like,
you know how they used to like,
um,
get people to give false confessions
by just keeping them awake for like 30
straight hours until they eventually,
like they don't know how to say no.
The fine I did it and stuff they did
didn't do, they weren't anywhere near it,
but they're just saying, yes, I
murdered somebody, let me sleep.
It's just a version of that, you
know, where you're just like,
he's just so sick of it.
After a while
I will tell you that they have read
about it and they say the people who talk
about suicide or sort of different, the
people who are thinking about it quietly,
quietly is weight way more
often to commit it. Um,
I think they say the people talking
about it as a way to seek help.
So what can you do it, the question
was what could you do to help people?
Is there anything that anybody
could have done? You know,
it used to make me mad when you told me
just get out of bed to some exercise.
I was like, you don't get it. You don't
get it. I definitely don't get it. Yeah.
Shandra understood at once. She was
like talking about that. She was like,
he doesn't understand. You can't even go
to your fridge. Like exercises. Not even,
it's just so far from like no way I
could couldn't even get out of bed.
What do you think was,
you were also taking Propecia then it
had anything to do with it because that's
one of the side event
I'm for sure might have.
I mean it was right around then and
I think, I'm trying to think, um,
if I was quitting right then on it
and switch into the fucking spread,
um, come on. Stem cell research.
But I think it was either on it or,
or, or getting off it. Yeah, for sure.
For sure. Could have had something to
do with that. Yeah, I think so too.
It was also, um, uh, live in girl.
I mean there was so many things right
around that. So all it takes is a sprain.
So like here's the weird thing.
Let's say you lost your job and that
sends you into depression. It's not,
that is not related to something.
A lot of times it will be related,
something a mom dies, dad dies.
But let's say the job situation,
because you can change this, right? Your
Dad dies, you'll never get them back.
You know, feels bad. And so like it
should feel bad. You lose your job,
you're going to depression, but now you
get a better job. You know what I mean?
Not that you will, but let's just
say you did the depression remains.
The causes of depression
is necessarily gone.
You're doing better than the
thing that made you depressed,
but you're still depressed
because that brain is sprained.
So you need a way to fight it.
And pills don't work for everybody,
so it's fucking disheartening.
And getting the right people.
I had a therapist say, well, I was like,
this, this one, pills not work. It's like,
wow, I don't know what to tell Ya. And I
was like, and in my head I was just like,
okay, I accept it all. Work
up the courage eventually,
and that'll be the end of it. I was like,
well, how am I going to fight you on it?
I don't want to fight this in the
first place. It's not going to work.
How she was the worst, what was it
like to get pulled out of the clouds?
Like when the pills that
pills started working, working
at first it,
it's like you don't trust that it's gone.
It's like right when the hiccups leave,
you still feel like you're
the hiccups, right? You know,
but like a way longer version of that.
And then what happens where it is you
start to miss it because it became so much
of your reality and who you were that
like it's this thing that's been pulled
away from you. A part of you is gone.
Hmm. So it's weird that you're like,
miss this horrible way of being,
um,
because you had to figure out a way
to like make a positive at this.
And you see this a lot in like PC culture,
we start sort of bragging about your
victimization or that things have happened
to you,
but like it's a way to stand out and be
a special that you ended up propping the,
the, the negative up instead of instead
of saying, yeah, that was Shitty,
you know, you started almost
like bragging about it, right?
So you start feeling like,
well at least I'm different.
So that can prop you up a little.
At least I'm unique in this thing of
like it doesn't seem like anyone else is
having these suicidal
thoughts, you know? Um,
it's almost like if you're
only the only one to do a band,
you feel better than if everyone else
into that same band. The band is,
the album is the album,
but you like it more because you're the
only one noticing your own uniqueness.
It's like, so maybe it was that, I'm not
really sure, but when I was out of it,
that was missing it a little bit and then
followed by a fear that it's going to
come back because regular d,
okay, that's a terrible word.
Depression because it also means
just, I'm depressed today. Right.
Clinical depression is
different, but overlaps, you
know, it doesn't just go away.
Right. If I'm depressed
because I'm cranky, I got to
tell myself, don't be cranky.
Say Five things. You're thankful for you.
She'll be out of it. Get some sunshine,
you're fine. This is like deeper. So
like then when you do get depressed,
like let's just say I
haven't been outside all day.
It's been raining for two straight days,
you know, he just a little like blue.
You're like, oh fuck,
is it back? You know?
And then when it's gone
in a day like Oh God,
but when it's like two days like
fuck fuck, fuck, don't come back.
Wow. Yeah. But the the,
so a bear like a bad weather day
could set it off a little bit. No,
that just gives like the normal depression
that everybody gets right at. That's,
I think I really should be two separate
terms. Feeling blue fill and blue,
which you, you get. He hadn't
been on stage in four days.
I feel a little blue if I,
if I,
I don't know if I can get my
underwear out all day too.
I can't live in Vancouver. Yeah, exactly.
Yeah. Those people get depressed.
You don't get outside Seattle.
They don't get outside while they get
outside where they get rained on. Yeah.
So it's just like he just feeling down.
I remember when Duncan and I were filming
something up there and we were doing
that big foot and we were talking to
this guy who was a cop who was like the
security guy for the set and
uh, he was like, dude, it
fucking wears on you. He was,
he was at the end of the rainy season.
It was just starting to get warm again.
Wears on that in New York. My first
New York went to was this one and it,
it wasn't so much middle of March
for, I was like, whatever I could,
I could take it. I took the winter, it
was middle of April where I'm like, uh,
Knopf already I put in the
three or four months. Oh,
so the question is the want though. What
the thing is, you could do what you want.
You could leave.
I could leave.
I went skiing a lot of the
16 days of skiing this year.
When did that around like road dates.
That's what's crazy about like somewhere
like Denver. Like it's sunny, sunny.
It's great. It's great. So much better
when it's sunny. It's cold out, but it's,
it's sunny.
Like if you have to pick warm and
cloudy all the time or cold and sunny.
I take cold and sunny all day long.
Yeah, for sure. All Day long. Sunny,
sunny skiing outside of the sun when it's
like, oh, it's good. It's 25 degrees.
But it's just, you don't even
walking around. Yeah, it's brisk out.
But look how pretty the sky is.
Blue,
blue sky and fluffy clouds. Did you
know Anthony Bordain was, was depressed?
No, I heard with him a little.
It was a mixture of mixing drugs,
mixing pills and alcohol
could have the hammer. I bow,
I believe he was on some
sort of malaria medication,
which is dangerous if some people,
um, violent people get violent.
I've seen people on malaria medication
while they were drinking. And, uh,
I had a hold the guy back from attacking
or a quarter or at least worried about
him attacking a report on.
So it was a friend of mine.
It was a very kind friend
of mine who I would,
I don't think we'd ever in normal
life attack a person physically.
And it seemed like he was about to,
it makes you think not even normal.
He was squirrely. Um, it was, he had
to go to Africa. If he had, he had, um,
visit somewhere in Africa and he had to
take these pills and some of them have
violent reactions to people. You're not
supposed to drink on them, first of all.
And he was drinking. It's
mixing. Yeah. And you know,
if that's what he was doing
and he's mixing that with
alcohol, who fucking knows?
So that could have happened
with board anywhere.
It might not have been
long term depression,
but I know there's studies on people
who have got a concussion in football
practice and then hung themselves
at night. Oh yeah. No history of it,
but right then everything. I mean, it's
almost like you're on psychedelics.
This new reality is real.
It feels real.
So I, the question is, is there something
you could've done? I don't know.
I don't know what the right,
I've thought about it.
I don't know what the right thing is.
Cause you, you push away people's help.
Right?
I saw somebody posted on Facebook once
where it was like one of the worst things
about depression is everybody going
to see, I've been through that too.
It's like if now I'm not even unique,
you know,
give me my props for my
individual substance.
So then it's like you want to help
by somebody who's saying, yeah,
I've been through this, but it's like,
it's not even helping them, but like
who the fuck knows what they're feeling?
Right.
That's the other thing about a person's
feelings, what they're feeling.
It's very personal. It's almost
impossible to describe. Oh, by the way,
I had moderate depression.
That's where the therapist said what
you saw was moderate depression. Jesus,
I don't know what severe depression
looks like. Jesus. So I don't know, man.
I don't know.
I lost somebody to,
and I don't know if I could have said
something to her or like, you know,
um, Anthony liked to drink.
He drank a lot. Yeah. And uh,
watching him over the last four years,
like you could see that he's,
he'd seemed like he had been
living a hard life. You know,
he looked like it on television too.
You've been living a hard life. I mean,
he was out there hitting it,
traveling from country to country,
constantly drinking constantly.
Alcohol's a depressant. It just is.
If you drink alcohol all the time,
you're not going to come out of it with
a sunny disposition as the present.
It is a depressant. I mean,
you can definitely do it
and pull it off. And we do.
And you know,
occasionally you'll have a couple of
drinks and then the next day you won't.
But if you're doing that all the time,
if you're doing it every day,
five days a week,
a lot of people use that because it's
a short term relief from depression,
longterm depressant.
So a lot of people use alcoholism
to cover up the depression.
And then they get clean.
Suddenly all the shit they're supposed
to have been dealing with is now still
there and not being covered
up by alcohol. Yeah. Yeah.
Fun that comes with a couple of drinks.
The, there's a fuck. Absolutely. It's fun.
Fuck it. Let's stop worrying. Yeah. It
would spend how addicted to it. I can't,
I wish I could do that with
cigarettes when everybody's smoking,
but I'll go right back to a pack. So
do you, do you, do you think like,
fuck, what could I have done? No,
because I wasn't close enough to them
and I wasn't there. If I was there,
I would be tortured by it.
Yeah.
If I was there and I was hanging out
with them and it happened in [inaudible]
tomorrow and then I would
have been tortured. Yeah.
That would then with anybody,
you know,
it's such a crazy decision to make the
decision to just stop living when so many
people loved you and you have
this crazy life that, uh,
it's the most bravest thing to me.
Yeah. I can't imagine something. It's,
that's the only thing that held me back
is just the lack of courage to be like,
just do it and it's like your DNA is
telling you, but stop and think about you.
What you've from not doing that
you become wildly successful. Yeah.
And way happier and you're
having a great fucking time.
I have the architect of my own happiness
and his fucking, I'm doing it well
doing it the way you're supposed
to do it, but you're, you know,
you've been doing it like this
for several years now and if you,
I guess it really doesn't matter in
the end, but if you end your own life,
you would have never
experienced all this true.
But if you had to go back and do it again,
it's interesting you were
at like a tipping point man,
you're this weird tipping point and
you just went that way and you're free.
Just took a while. It was
definitely a struggle. But you,
you were free I find
when talking to comics,
other comics because now I
feel a little guilty, you know,
for success around around people that
are also quite funny who don't have it.
And what I found is that it's,
you get this frustrating point run around
eight nine 10 12 years of comedy where
like your skills have gotten better
and your monetary career has not gotten
better.
Seo,
artistic careers booming and then
you're just not even making a living.
And it's the most frustrating cause
like I'm finally good at open mic level.
Like, or make a good joke that's a window
and sewn. I made a good joke tonight,
this week or one time this month,
you know? But like they are,
it's like I'm doing so well on
stage. I'm killing. Why am I,
why am I still working this day job?
Why am I not even ever on TV? Why am I,
you know,
it's real frustrating.
It might've been around that time too
or just getting frustrated with like,
you know, I was less hacky
but also just not succeeding.
Is it interesting how the Internet's
changed everything or for,
you can support people so much easier.
Before it was like you had the man show,
you could hire a writer and that's it.
That's the only help you could
do for someone. Yeah. You know,
take a couple people on the road with
you, but then now it's like, Hey,
go watch this guy show, hey,
this guy's got into special. Hey,
check out so and so's got a new book.
You know, changes everything. Yeah.
And people are going, it's literally no
skin off your back. Yeah. It's like, well,
it's great. You're
actually, it's good. Like I,
if Tom Papa asked me to
promote something he's doing,
I want people to go see him.
It's good. It's good for me.
I want him to do good because I like
listening to him. I like watching them,
so I want them to make more
comedy. Oh yeah. Then you went,
because I get to see you more.
I got to get to sell out comedy.
Good person gets to stay in it. Not
that he needs us, but it also will,
like with Tom, when you tell people
about someone who's really funny,
whether it's you or whoever it
is, then they trust you. They go,
I want to see that guy.
He's a fucking Lexus.
They know that you're telling the truth.
Like if I tell him, Hey Joey Diaz,
the funniest guy that's ever lived and
you go see him at the Ice House one night
and come out of it, you,
you're bleeding from your,
your internal bruising for laughing.
I love guaranteeing people on Twitter
or whatever. It's like, you don't know.
I guarantee you will have a great night.
There's someone who's an awesome comic.
Just, just, there's no like,
well my friend. It's like,
just, they'll be great. Yeah.
There's, there's people that you could do
that with, but yeah, there was, you know,
before it was like you got on the
tonight show, you know, he did.
So that was an actual time that I
let her man, people talked about,
you had to build up places,
you had to travel to places all the time.
So those people would come
back every time they came back.
You better have some new shit, dude,
I really got to think about it.
I have like when you start saying that
depression of paypal, like what can you,
what can I do? Anybody do? Is
there anything anybody can do?
It's like just a little bit
like being there for you.
Sometimes it's helpful.
Just be like, hey man,
you're just your good friend.
I know you're going through something,
but just know that I like you just like
a little bit and don't require anything
of them, but I guess everybody
be different too, but like,
I don't know, don't know. Everybody's
on a different trip. That's the thing.
It's like no one knows
what anyone is feeling.
Telling someone to get over it
is not the way to do it. That's,
that ain't going to help.
The tough love thing.
It's like that doesn't work.
That works for fucking nothing.
I don't know what it works for, but not
that it works for lazy people. Yeah,
exactly. I don't think it works for them.
I don't even think it works for them.
I think that gets people
to move sometimes,
but it doesn't change the way they
think about what they're doing.
They just get forced into doing it.
You know? It's like the argument,
well actually not like that when
I was going to say, but it's,
it's you,
you want them to act and so they act
because of force of your your will. Right.
Trying to scare them into it. Yeah. But
if you inspire someone and say to him,
listen,
I know you're looking at it this way,
but this is why this is going to
hurt you by approaching it this way.
You're going to do the same thing.
But instead of approaching it the
way you're approaching it, stop.
And just for a shift of perspective,
think about it in a positive way.
Like you could do that to people and
sometimes you can actually shift the way
they look at something because a lot of
times it's the way you're approaching
something that's pissing you off about it.
And the way to get through sometimes to
people is not to tell them this is the
way you should do it.
But just to paint the picture and let
them make their own decision. Yeah.
To be like, oh, so you're happy
when you're run? Yeah. Okay.
Is it, is it warm out? Oh,
it is. Okay. I don't know. You're less
happening. You don't run. Alright. Well,
it was like, instead of be like, you got
to get out there and run. I, you know,
I have kids raising kids.
One of the things that I learned that
works really good is anytime they do
anything, I tell them I fucked
up way worse than you. I
don't use the word fucked.
All right? And I said, whatever you've
done, I've messed up way more like I,
everybody messes.
Don't worry about it.
This is a part of being a kid and I'm
super proud of you for admitting that you
made a mistake or that you did this. This
is great because this is how you learn.
You're not supposed to know everything.
You're eight years old or
you're 10 years old. You're,
you're supposed to be learning,
learning about life and those people
who are supposed to be talking about
various things you encounter. You don't
supposed to already know everything.
You're a little kid.
This is great.
So we learned something that we don't
want to do anymore. This is great.
This is an awesome opportunity.
And nobody,
I wished somebody talked to me like
that and I will tell them that too.
I go cause I get called stupid
and yelled at or whatever.
Whatever the fuck it was
when I did something.
This is how people talk to kids
back then they didn't, you know,
it's not even anybody's fault.
Someone does something dumb. You know,
in the 1960s or something like that. They
threw things at them. You know, like my,
my parents were telling me about things
flying across the room at them, you know,
like people stop,
they just fucking that little,
the kids were animals back then
too. You know, people are different.
Yeah. Yeah. So it might be that
like something that helped me,
I don't know if people are listening
are going through it or whatever,
but like some things that have helped
that I was able to take was I had one
therapist said one good
thing where he's like,
imagine the good things out
of the depression. Yeah.
Instead of looking at it as only
negative, um, what's it helped you with?
And then I was like, Ooh, I'm
going to try that. And it was like,
I'm looking at my standup material more
realistically and darker and that's
actually helpful on stage.
He's like, all right, cool.
That's one good thing out of this.
And then it just like sort of,
it might just help you like it's not
all bad. Adjust the way you approach it.
Yeah. Another thing was say five
things and just in the shower,
whenever you do shower, say five things
out loud that you were thankful for.
Doesn't have to be monumental stuff.
Just like it's 75 today. That's good. Um,
I got a new bar soap. That's cool. Um, uh,
my friend John, you know, whatever,
Brian, I like him. That's cool.
A lot of have that in my life.
Just five things to say it out loud.
And then after a while some of that
that ended up affecting my mood. Hmm.
You know where instead of,
cause that was the problem was the focus.
I don't know if I ever told you this
thought it was a negative thing. Yeah.
So it'd be like a 75 degree day. This is
the example I use 75 degrees and sunny.
It's fucking every day in La,
you know? And I would be like,
instead of going like this is fucking Rad,
it's February 12th and I am
fucking in shorts, this is great.
Instead of focusing in that, I
would focus on like fuck, I got,
I got my car has no gas,
I got to fucking go get gas.
I hate having to fucking get gas.
You got to pull over.
And so then I'm only focusing on
this fucking one minute chore,
but I have to do instead of on all
the good stuff. And so you just focus.
It just makes you focus on this
negative and he's just like,
can't pull out of it.
So anything you can do to like shift
the focus to the positive is helpful.